عارضات الأزياء الذين كانوا يسيرون أولاً عبر الأنفاق المضيئة المضيئة في برادا قبل الخروج إلى شاطئ مشمس من الرمال البيضاء ، بدا عرض الأزياء الأخير في برادا بمثابة استعارة واضحة لعالم خرج من جائحة فيروس كورونا ، دار الأزياء الإيطالية التي ظهرت لأول مرة في خط الملابس الرجالية على شواطئ سردينيا ذات المناظر الخلابة بينما كان البحر الأبيض المتوسط المذهل بنفس القدر كانت فيستا هي الخلفية لأحدث عروض أزياء ديور ، وهي العلامة التجارية الفرنسية الفاخرة التي كشفت النقاب عن مجموعتها من الرحلات البحرية في الاستاد الباناثيني الذي يعود تاريخه إلى 2000 عام في اليونان احتفالًا بالأزياء الراقية والتاريخ اليوناني ، حيث يقوم المصممون بكل ما هو ممكن لإغراء المستهلكين المتعطشين لتجربة الناس سيرغب في الذهاب والقيام بالأشياء حتى بكثافة أكبر وبسرور أكبر مما كانوا يفعلونه من قبل لأننا نقدر عدم وجود كل شيء نحب أن نعرفه أثناء السفر وتناول الطعام في المطاعم وزيارة الفنادق واكتشاف الأماكن وشراء المحاضرات قال رئيس ديور والمدير التنفيذي لـ CNN التي تستثمر فيها الشركة بكثافة
العقارات في واجهة المتجر
أثناء العمل أيضًا على جعل قنواتهم الرقمية
امتدادًا أكثر سلاسة
للتسوق داخل المتجر ، إنها خطوة نحو
تجارة التجزئة التجريبية التي
يبدو أيضًا أن قادة الصناعة الآخرين يتبنون
إعادة الافتتاح الكبرى برفقة
الرئيس الفرنسي ، حيث رسموا خطوطًا من المتسوقين
في باريس
بعد  قامت مجموعة السلع الفاخرة lvmh بتمويل
إحياء مركز تسوق عمره 150
عامًا تم إغلاقه منذ 2005.
إنهم يأملون في الحصول على شريحة أكبر
من الإنفاق السياحي مع تخفيف قيود السفر الوبائي
ولكن تجار التجزئة المتميزين يتطلعون إلى
الاستفادة من الارتفاع المتوقع  من
المتسوقين داخل المتجر جيدًا ، قد يضطرون إلى
التعامل
مع الجمهور الذي
اعتاد ارتداء الملابس الداخلية بالتأكيد أكثر
استرخاءً ،
لقد ارتديت بالتأكيد بدلة رياضية
للعمل عدة مرات
يسير الأشخاص إلى المكتب أكثر من
عدم ركوب القطار ، لذلك  لقد
ارتدوا أحذية مريحة وأشياء من هذا القبيل ، لذا
نعم بالتأكيد أكثر استرخاء
خلال الجائحة الرياضية وملابس
الاسترخاء التي تسمى أيضًا  شهدت thleisure
نموًا هائلاً
مع شركات مثل lululemon التي زادت
من حصتها في السوق ، في
حين أن الحاجة إلى العمل من
الملابس المنزلية قد تهدأ الآن هذا الاتجاه
جزئيًا هو السبب في إفلاس
بعض
العلامات التجارية الراسخة التي ترتدي ملابس رسمية أكثر
عقبة رئيسية أخرى تتمثل في الاهتمام المتزايد
بالأزياء المستدامة
نظرًا لأن المستهلكين أصبحوا أكثر وعياً
بدور الصناعة في أزمة المناخ
وفقًا للبنك الدولي ، فإن القطاع
يمثل حوالي 10 في المائة من
انبعاثات الكربون العالمية كل عام وهو أكثر
من جميع
الرحلات الجوية الدولية
والشحن البحري مجتمعين
في صناعتي نفسها ، أعتقد أن
هناك  رغبة كبيرة في إجراء تغييرات إيجابية ،
أعتقد فقط أن الناس لا يعرفون حقًا
كيفية القيام بذلك ، ومع ذلك
فإن صناعتنا تتغير ، وآمل أن تكون
حقيقة أننا
جميعًا قد انضممنا إلى هذا الوباء
ونأمل أن ندرك جميعًا أننا
بحاجة فعلاً  لتكون
أكثر لطفًا مع كوكبنا سواء كان ذلك
تجاه الاستدامة التي
تسعى إليها العلامات التجارية ذات الخبرة الحسية أو الملابس الأكثر استرخاءً  إنه يميل بشكل صحيح
نحو المطالب المتوقعة للمستهلكين حيث
يجد عمالقة الموضة مثل أي شخص آخر موطئ قدم لهم
في سيباستيان المستقبل بعد التغطية.